eine invasion aus dem all in gleich zwei
aktuelle studien warnen
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
eindringlich vor dem bio
sicherheitsrisiko weltraum befürchtet
wird zum einen eine art alien invasion
aber auch anders herum gibt es ein
großes risiko nämlich dass organismen
ungewollt von der erde ins all getragen
werden mit dramatischen folgen was muss
jetzt getan werden klicks umsatz im
future geht es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasste nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen erst vor zwei jahren
passierte der unfall ein israelischer
mond länder stürzte im sommer 2009 10
über dem erdtrabanten ab antwort hat er
tausende schlafende bärtierchen es
handelt sich um wirbellose tierchen die
auch die härtesten lebensbedingungen
nicht fürchten egal ob eisige
temperaturen hohe strahlenbelastung oder
extreme trockenheit bärtierchen können
all dem trotzen in der fachsprache wird
dieser unfall aufgrund technischen
versagens als versehentliche vorwärts
kontamination bezeichnet organismen
werden also ungewollt ins all getragen
und genau das ist eines von zwei
szenarien vor den wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler jetzt eindringlich
warnen die rede ist von bio
sicherheitsrisiken bedingt durch die
raumfahrt die fachleute warnen
eindringlich davor diese zu ignorieren
da sonst zitat extreme folgen drohen was
genau könnte die zweite gefahr einer
alien-invasion auf der erde auslösen was
passiert wenn wir durch mond oder mars
missionen das weltall kontaminieren und
was haben damit private
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex von ihnen
masken zu tun die spannenden antworten
auf all diese fragen gibt es jetzt hier
bei klicks umsatz im future schon lange
wissen wir dass bakterien in der lage
sind im weltall zu überleben und das
unter den widrigsten bedingungen
eigentlich handelt es sich um einen
extrem lebensfeindlichen ort bei
sonneneinstrahlung kann es zu
temperaturen von bis zu plus 100 grad
celsius kommen aber auch minus 270 grad
celsius sind möglich genau deswegen
auch in den menschen ja so einige
schutzmaßnahmen um uns sicher durch den
welt kommt zu bewegen doch wie sieht das
bei bakterien aus dazu wurden bereits
vor einigen jahren experimente auf der
internationalen raumstation iss
durchgeführt konkret hatten die
fachleute bakterien des stamms die ihn
nur kokos radio duran für drei jahre an
der außenhülle der iss den krassen
bedingungen des weltalls ausgesetzt und
hier sieht es ja nicht nur extreme
temperaturschwankungen sondern auch das
vakuum das die existenz von leben
erschwert oder sogar unmöglich macht an
bord einer space rakete wurden die
bakterien 2 ss gebracht und dort auf
platten aufgebracht die dann durch einen
mechanischen arm von der außenhülle der
iss ins all gehalten wurden drei ganze
jahre verwalten die bakterien dann im
weltall bis sie dann wieder an bord der
iss geholt wurden und das ergebnis war
verblüffend denn die bakterien hatten
tatsächlich überlegt die fachleute
fanden zwar heraus dass die äußere
schicht der bakterien abgestorben war
doch das erbgut hatte keineswegs schaden
genommen ganz im gegenteil die bakterien
hatten eine art schutzschirm um ihre dna
gebildet die i-know cocos radio duran
verfügt nach angaben der fachleute sogar
über einen mechanismus der selbstheilung
so können sie beschädigt teile der dna
stränge durch kopien ersetzen forschende
gehen aufgrund solcher experimente sogar
davon aus dass bakterien eine reise von
der erde zum mars überstehen würden und
zwar ungeschützt strahlung im oder am
raumschiff austrocknung oder nicht
vollständige sterilisation könnten sogar
dafür sorgen dass die organismen immer
toleranter werden was die
lebensbedingungen im weltall oder auf
fremden planeten angeht in der
fachsprache würde damit ihr sogenanntes
invasions potenzial steigen eine große
gefahr wie jetzt wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler von den
australischen universitäten adelaide und
melbourne im fachmagazin bioscience
schreiben sie sind beunruhigt und waren
vor ungeahnten auswirkungen durch
eingeschleppte mikroorganismen demnach
mangelt es an ausreichenden regelungen
für reisen und missionen in den weltraum
und da die raumfahrt industrie
expandiert sein zitat gute bio
sicherheitsmaßnahmen bringen gut wenn
ich das risiko der biologe inversion sei
groß schreibt das forschungsteam dabei
beruft er sich auf zahlreiche
fallbeispiele die sich so auf der erde
zugetragen haben mit dem begriff
invasion meinen wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler die ausbreitung von
organismen in neuartigen umgebung in
denen diese bis zu diesem zeitpunkt als
fremd gehalten fest steht dass dadurch
die nachhaltigkeit der ökosysteme
gestört wird und auch das menschliche
wohlergehen leidet menschen haben in
zahlreichen fällen gebietsfremde
mikroben wirbeltiere pflanzen und
wirbellose in allen regionen dieser erde
verbreitet sogar entlegensten gebiete
wie den polar alpen und tiefs regionen
dieser erde sind davon betroffen es gibt
beispielsweise starke hinweise darauf
dass wir menschen versehentlich
arzneimittel resistente darmbakterien in
das antarktische öko system eingeführt
haben seevögel und robben haben sich
bereits infiziert dazu werden funktionen
von ökosystemen tiefgreifend verändert
wie unter anderem der nährstoff
kreislauf oder die kohlenstoff bindung
zahlreiche studien haben in der
vergangenheit eindrucksvoll bewiesen
dass manche invasion tatsächlich zu
einem erheblichen verlust der
biologischen vielfalt führen und nicht
nur das auch die menschliche gesundheit
kann somit geschädigt und unsere
lebensgrundlagen angegriffen werden doch
die gefahr ist neben nicht nur auf der
erde real sondern auch bezogen auf den
weltraum organismen könnten von uns
menschen also unbeabsichtigt ins all
getragen werden in der fachsprache ist
von einer so genannten vorwärts
kontamination die rede doch es geht auch
anders herum und auch das ist ein risiko
mikroben könnten ungewollt mit zur erde
gebracht werden und hier ökosysteme
kontaminieren auch als sogenannte
rückwärts kontamination bezeichnet die
forschenden man hier übrigens nicht
grüne männchen oder hochentwickelte
organismen vielmehr geht es ihnen um
mikroorganismen dazu ein studie fordern
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler deswegen dass diese
genannten risiken durch die
raumfahrtindustrie anerkannt werden ein
breiteres spektrum von akteuren als dies
jemals möglich war können dass alle
erforschen und nutzen die gesteigerte
aktivität im all ändere das risikoprofil
nach ansicht der fachleute dramatisch
die bisherigen rahmenbedingungen seien
auf ein solches szenario nicht
vorbereitet dazu sagt einer der mit die
forscher für casey der weltraum
entwickelt sich zu einer neuen grenze
des bio sicherheitsrisikos wir müssen
jetzt maßnahmen ergreifen um diese
risiken zu mindern die fachleute
sprechen von extremen folgen die diese
gefahren mit sich bringen wird wichtig
sind demnach drei handlungs punkte auf
die geachtet werden muss erstens
vorsorge zweitens früh erkennen und
drittens eine schnelle reaktion um
erkennen zu können was einheimisch und
was fremd ist hier müssten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus der astrobiologie und physik mit
entsprechenden fachleuten zusammen
kommen die zu invasiven arten auf der
erde forschen gemeint sind damit
pflanzen und tiere die aus ihrem
natürlichen
verbreitungsgebieten in andere
ökosysteme einwandern oder eingeschleppt
werden gründe dafür sind nicht nur der
globale handel und der reiseverkehr
sondern auch der klimawandel werden
hierbei klicks um 20 user beispielsweise
schon über die tigermücke als eine
sogenannte invasive art berichtet ein
ähnlich eindringliche warnung kommt von
einem weiteren forschungsteam befürchtet
wird hier eine zitat alien-invasion auch
das internationale forschungsteam meint
aber damit bakterien die es durch die
raumfahrt aus dem weltraum auf die erde
verschlagen könnte dazu sagt der ökologe
anthony ricciardo aus kanada der
weltraum entwickelt sich zu einem neuen
bio sicherheitsrisiko die forderung hier
sind sehr ähnlich aus diesen gründen
müssen verbesserte protokolle für den
nachweis von mikroben während
interplanetare missionen entwickelt
werden invasions biologinnen und
biologen sollten dringend in die
entwicklung von regeln zum planetaren
schutz mit einbezogen werden protokolle
für eine frühzeitige entdeckung
gefahrenmanagement und eindämmung
verfahren zu invasive spezies auf der
erde müssten dringend für mögliche
außerirdische invasion angepasst werden
und hier geht's zum video über die
tigermücke folge des klimawandels
menschen killer nummer eins wird in
deutschland heimisch also einfach
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren das
geht ganz einfach mit dem abo button
unter jedem video bis dann bleibt